-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-Very happy to have you here.
-Happy to be here.
-So, this is --
From the clip,
we can tell, you´re --
Well, I guess we don´t
really know who the good guy
or the bad guy is in the clip.
But you´re kind of
an old-school villain in this.
-Yeah.
Oh, he´s definitely got
bad tendencies.
He´s got some --
He´s got some issues
he´s working out,
you know, with his gun.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That was a big issue
with people in the old West,
was their bad tendencies.
-Apparently.
Apparently.
You know, it was 1880s.
He needs a shrink.
He really needs a shrink.
-And there was only, like,
one shrink per town.
-Per state.
-Oh, per state.
-Per state, you know.
-Very hard.
-Yeah, so it´s just kind of
walking around,
spinning around
with a lot of
mental health issues.
-And did you --
Obviously, this seems
very different from you,
to play a Western villain.
Did you enjoy that?
-I loved it,
because it is the bucket list.
I mean, every actor wants
to be in a Western
until you´re in a Western
and you realize you
don´t want to be
in a Western anymore,
because you´ve got to ride
those damn horses.
-Right.
-Because I´m -- you know,
I´m not -- I´m from Michigan.
I didn´t grow up on a --
You know, a horse-riding --
-Famously, Michigan put horses
out of business.
-Did we?
Did we?
So, I got trained
by a guy in Michigan
that taught the
county mounted division.
He was a rodeo -- It was great.
Because if I hadn´t done that,
it would have been --
I would have fallen off
more than three times.
´Cause I fell off, thrown off...
-Three times?
-Three times.
Yeah, over three months.
Yeah, which is a
pretty good batting average.
-Yeah.
-For actors.
-Yeah, for actors.
For horsemen, it´s terrible.
-There´s such an attitude
with the wranglers.
The wranglers, you know --
I mean, these guys,
they´re just, you know,
walking around like this
all of the time.
[ Light laughter ]
And they´re looking at
the pretty-boy actors
from Hollywood who said,
"We can -- Oh, I can ride.
Absolutely."
We can´t ride.
-Yeah.
-And they literally --
You´re galloping,
and you´ve got a wrangler
and a wrangler on both sides
who look like outlaws
and their whole job is
to save your ass
when something goes wrong.
And it will go wrong.
I mean,
it´s like motorcycle riding.
There are people
who have gone down
and people who are going
to go down.
It´s just a matter of time.
-Right, exactly.
Did you ever ask for a horse
that was lower to the ground?
Did you --
[ Laughter ]
Did that ever come up?
-I didn´t want --
I got to be a bad guy,
and I´m leading real men.
Real outlaws.
And I can´t be
on a Shetland pony.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Can´t do it.
-Can´t do it.
-I can´t do it.
-Well, I don´t think this is
much of a spoiler,
because it happens
in the first episode,
but your character
also loses an arm.
I do lose an arm.
-So then, you have to ride
with one arm.
-Yeah.
Not only can you not ride, and
you´re going to have to learn,
but you´re going to have to
learn to ride with one arm.
So out of all the --
You´re only --
You have two arms, like,
for a day out of three months.
So it´s all about this.
And, you know, for --
You´ve got the special --
First of all, you´re riding,
and it´s -- you know.
Where´s your balance?
Oh, here it is.
-You actually had a disadvantage
over someone who actually has
one arm, because your arm is
still there, like,
leading you to be
even more imbalanced.
-Yeah.
And it´s great fun when
you´re spending eight hours
on a horse,
and you´ve got to shove
it down the crack as far as
you can get it.
[ Laughter ]
You know, wedge it in there.
Because we can´t see the arm.
It can´t be this.
It´s got to be this.
Okay.
All right.
And, action!
Big speech.
Cry.
[ Cheers and applause ]